và dụng tên 2, đúng không?
Li đổ tiên này bột đoạn như là công thức này
trong tập nhất, ở trên là công thức trong phương trình cho bạn nghĩ là tự nhiệt
bây giờ, này, bối, tỷ số quay, những quay trên tây làm hàng số
hai thác, cho các muốn chuyển được chẳng ai của tây tây tây tây tây tây tây tây tây tây
á, tuy là hả?
nhá, bê một, bê một, bê một, bê một, trên tây một, hảm, bê hai, bê hai, trên tây hát
bây giờ, bây giờ, bây giờ tuyệt có tương này thì các bạn có thích mắc là cái thằng hàng số
để nói là cái gì?
Bình cho thang kê bình và tự nhiên công thức này còn thích gì nữa
là, là, là, là, đặc năng xuống mình sẽ phục thuộc và gì được tây đổi
đúng không?
á, đúng là xuống mình sẽ phục tây đổi
nhá, bây giờ, là, mài ra thì tây sẽ có thể một các thức mũ xuống
nữa, phát, nên nếu không phải thlan, á sất, cho tự khi,
thế giới là, bây giờ, tình, bật tốc, cân, cân, phương, bây giờ,
là, sẽ bằng căng bật hai của vế bình Trung mình
và bằng căng bật bà cát tên trên mở, và bằng căng bộ,
bà, rộn tây, cho chí trong mình,
đại, phục đeóng, cái cái này là bình hộ
họ là, mình có thức liên quan đến tốc độ trong mình,
thế giới là, những câu thức và đồng vụ xuống tây,
để các bạn đến điều thế, với các bạn ghi vài doang,
nhá, và những câu thức trên, thì nó sẽ là,
là câu thức trách, đoang, để các bạn sử dụng vàng vụ trong các bạn doang,
có thể là trong những chiều học này, nhá,